welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning
you know that this is the place where i
want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career and
today's topic
is a fan favorite it's a topic that many
of you have already requested
and this is the famous dreaded
consulting
bag how do you pack your bag as a
consultant
this is what we're going to discuss
today i will show you how i packed my
bag as a consultant in the past and i
will share some tricks which have my
perspective what you will likely need
what you probably won't need and
probably what can be a life saver in
certain situations
so before we dive into it let me start
by providing some context
so as you know if you've seen some other
videos on my channel
the typical work week in the life of a
consultant is that from monday to
thursday
you are at the client so usually monday
morning you take the first flight in the
morning
to fly out fly to the client then you
fly back thursday evening
and this for this reason requires you of
course to have a well-packed bag
to live through the week of course at
the moment due to the current health
situation
the rhythm looks a bit different travel
is down
people are not traveling that much
there's more home office they also know
that travel is already starting to pick
up again slowly so trust that this will
become more relevant for you
in the future again so let's start by
talking about the exterior because there
are some little things
that you can do as well and one of the
main problems that you will face
is that many many consultants will use
very similar bags so at the airport
there were lots of bags that pretty much
look the same
so my tip is use something like this a
little
piece of something just to mark your bag
that everybody knows that this is yours
and that you can quickly distinguish it
from other bags as well
and of course a proper luggage tag with
the information with your personal
details
will be helpful so that in case you lose
it in case somebody else
finds this they know who you are and how
they can reach you
so why do consultants even care so much
what exactly they pack into their bag
and the main reason is that you will not
check your luggage
so you can only bring hand luggage and
the reason is that it would just take
too much time
if after you land you go to the luggage
bed conveyor you wait for your piece of
baggage to pick it up
the team wants to directly take the taxi
take the cab to the client once you land
so everybody will just pick up hand
luggage there will be no
checked in luggage so let's start how
these bags are structured and of course
the different types of luggages will be
different
but usually have one compartment where
it's more free float right in one
compartment where you have
a fixed thing that you can make over it
to really keep it all in place
and i like to have the things which are
a bit more delicate like the shirts
where you don't want to have too many
wrinkles after you iron them to have
them rather than this part
because this is then how you keep it all
together how you make sure that it's all
in it
so let's start indeed with the shirts
and here what you need to understand is
that on monday morning
you will already drive to the client and
then fly to the client
fully dressed so in your suit in your
shirt and so on so for monday you
already wear your outfit
this means that you still need outfits
for tuesday wednesday and thursday
so three days but then it's a good best
practice
to always have an additional one in
store with you so that for instance if
for whatever reason you might need to
stay there
for another day spontaneously that you
would be able to stay there for instance
on friday as well
without running out of clothes so it's
best practice to really have
four clothes with you four pieces of
shirts
and of course here types of shirts you
see here so i might make another video
in the future
talking a bit more about this typical
consultant outfit what types of shirts
what types of shoots you're supposed to
wear but like usual plain colors white
blue
some simple stripes this is what's
usually okay this is what you will wear
most of the time
so let's start with them indeed and of
course here the critical thing is how
you fold them
because you want to make sure that
they're not too wrinkled when you then
unpack them in the hotel
so simple way of doing it after your
iron is do it like this
put these arms here together and then
fold it once like this to have such a
package
then i take this package and try to fit
this
into this half here and here now you
might do some
delicate additional folding just of
course
the less folding you do the better for
this
in order to fit this in properly the
next item to take care of is your
underwear
and here for the same logic you already
wear your things on monday then you need
four more days to be covered until
friday
and then my recommendation is to bring
even one additional one
in case you want to do some sports so
for instance one pair of sport socks
this always makes sense so you have five
additional pieces of underwear
now if you look here in the compartment
where we put the shirts
here it makes sense to then stuff this a
little bit here in the free spaces
because this will then help the sole
area not to move so much
and the less it all moves the less
wrinkles the less problems you get
with ironing your shirts afterwards
so once you've all put it in then you
can close this
and this then should make sure that this
is more or less
firmly secured and then this first half
part of the bag is done once you then
unpack your bag in the hotel it always
makes sense to check
how wrinkly your shirts really are and
indeed most business hotels enough
opportunity
to help you them with the ironing or to
provide you the facilities so that you
can then
iron the shirts in the perfect way if
they're too wrinkly for you to wear them
next point is the shoes and this is
always a question of personal philosophy
because indeed in such a bag you usually
only have place for one
additional pair of shoes so you will
already wear your business shoes on
monday
so the question is what is the second
pair that you bring and some colleagues
like to bring a second pair of business
shoes so then they can alternate the
shoes during the week
this of course can make a lot of sense
and will help you to really keep the
shoes
in a well looking place for the long
term personally i always like to
prioritize
sports so i always brought a pair of
running shoes that i have this with me
and this is then indeed something that
you can just then pack in the second
half
i usually did it in some way like this
to have the shoes in here in the section
i often frankly also use the shoe bag to
make sure that the potentially dirty
shoes
are not making other things dirty here
as well so for the sake of simplicity
i'm not having this here but i need you
could pack the suction in a simple
garbage bag a simple plastic garbage bag
for instance to have this clean and
secured here
next is a leisure outfit this is a
little bit optional not all colleagues
do this but sometimes it can be nice
and this is for some evenings with your
colleagues or maybe it's nice to go to
the hotel first to change
do they not keep continuing wearing your
dress shirt that you wear all day from
work
so here indeed most colleagues will do
this anyway
so it's not absolutely required but
sometimes it's nice just to have a
normal pair
of trousers and just a normal polo shirt
or something like this that you can wear
and do not need to walk around with your
business outfit all the time so this is
something that you can just put in here
to make this work for you the next one
is your sports outfit so we already have
the shoes and the running socks
in the back now of course a pair of
running trousers and then a running
shirt
will be helpful and appreciated
depending on the sport that you do
you of course might also be taking other
material
that you need to make this work for you
next one is something to keep you a bit
warm and here most people either have an
additional
jumper that they take with them or maybe
also a west
like this so often there's not enough
space to take both personally i like to
have something like this it's a rest
this is always nice and you can also
wear it in the team room
under your suit for instance so this is
always a nice addition
that's often worthwhile just to pack and
to have with you
when you pack your bag next one is ties
so these days you do not need to wear a
tire at every client but there are still
some clients that will require you to
wear them but this is just part of the
dress code
you're just good to have selection of
basic colors nothing too crazy
like dark blue red green these are
colors that i personally like to wear
and here indeed if you know that you
will need a tie then pack enough make
sure that you have three or four that
you can really alternate during the week
but even if you had a client where you
do not expect that you need to wear a
tie where you know that you actually
don't need to do that
it's always good practice to have at
least one tie with you
so if in case maybe you are suddenly
meeting somebody else a senior person
maybe also outside of the organization
on a short notice need to join
another workshop another pitch maybe
even have another client that you are
flexible
that you have a tie with you that you
can wear if this is then required
for the setting that you're in and here
often it's good just to roll it a bit
make sure that you don't knit it too
hard but a simple row like this is fine
where then put it in the back
and make this work in a proper way and
last but not least your
toilet bag with all the sanitary things
that you need during your stay in the
hotel
so here the good thing is if you are
missing something if you got something
at home
most of these business hotels will be
able to provide you with
all the basic things like a toothpaste
for instance
but it's of course always nicer to have
your own things that you can then bring
so indeed i would just always also pack
it here to the side make sure that it
doesn't interfere too much with your
ties
and then these days of course some
additional corona masks is always
helpful to have this in the back as well
to then have it here when you need it so
these are all the essentials indeed
after you have all this
you can pack it up make sure it all fits
well and you see this
nicely fills out such a hand luggage
this is now also a small size these days
they're even a bit larger sizes of hand
luggage that are allowed
to be brought into the the cabin of the
airplane
so this is fine you see that you can
easily close this
so that's it and from my experience this
is the setup that works really well this
is how i did it most of the time
some colleagues like to bring a second
suit
and hear the rationale as well if you
only have one suit with you that you're
wearing on monday of course you're
risking it then maybe
you spill some coffee over it maybe your
trousers
have no problem there's maybe a damage
maybe they rip apart and then of course
you have quite
some problems then you have nothing else
to wear anymore this is now one of the
reasons why some people like to bring a
second
suit and then of course you can bring a
simple suit back like this
this works that you can then often put
it together you can then carry it
and then you can also have it here
around the back if you then travel
around the airport
this can work and if you have this the
additional benefit of using this is that
if you then open it you can use this
also as a place just have some other
things by opening it and just putting
more stuff here in the bottom
so this can then just be used for
additional space
so personally i did not do this i did
not take this with me most of the time i
rather prefer the leaner setup
and indeed for these cases where maybe
really you spill tea on your trousers or
anything like this
i just like to take rather one pair of
trousers from pair of leisure trousers
like the one that i'm currently wearing
here right now because this is a trowel
that in the worst case
you might also be able just to bring to
the client wear with a dress shirt
and then maybe you're not wearing a suit
but it will still look proper and will
give you this one additional day that it
might need you to just pick up another
dress travel summaries so that was my
routine how i
did it most of the time but i also want
to stress that there's nothing like the
golden rule book
of how you need to pack your bag as a
consultant and if you ask
different people they will come up with
different suggestions different styles
different things that are important to
them what you bring with them so here
i'd also love to hear your views your
opinions as well
leave me a comment in the comment
section below the video to let me know
what your tips and tricks were what the
things were that you did
into your bag and i will do my very best
to answer every single comment that you
write
so as always if you took any value out
of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
the channel to stay up to date on all my
content
i also have an instagram where you can
see even more content from me
my handle is firm learning there and if
you want to learn even more about
consulting i have one signature course
about slide writing
about how to create presentations in the
style of leading consulting firms
if you're interested in that i have over
10 000 students who took the course
already
there's a link to the course in the
video description check it out
and now i also want to say a big thank
you to all the members of firm learning
you're really making a big contribution
to the channel thanks so much for your
support
and if you want to become a member as
well hit the join button next to the
subscribe button
to check it all out my name is heinrich
i release new videos every single
saturday on my channel
so talk to you again next week next
saturday until then good weekend to all
of you
this is honey from from learning bye